we're kind of like winding out the day  from Florence and her sister is like yo  so I was kind of talking to the wedding  planner and um have you guys thought  about this have you thought about that  and we're like oh yeah the ceremony her  sister's like you're like a best man or  anything I'm like no is anyone getting  ready with you and I was like I thought  I was just gonna put on my suit and just  play a tower defense game on my phone  and then just walk out there like when  it's time for my set and she's like and  she's like no dude that's not how you do  this funny the efficient is like next up  big round of applause for Noel Miller  everyone on the stage right now you know  him he's sleeping with the with the with  our headlining act tonight yeah yeah  they've been together for a long time  Make some noise for Noel Miller right  now yeah thank you thank you